Democrats are getting her asses kicked
we need some way to road-test a more
rural friendly message if you can't live
your principles into bad times I guess
they are principles they just hobbies
nice John Wayne and a tractor have a
baby and all you can say it's nice oh my
god
Carl Jack Hastings is our key back into
the great now swing state of Wisconsin
he just doesn't know it yet can I be
completely honest with you no bulb be
nice my daughter's here that was your
guard with her arm up the cacao guys
like me don't know how to talk guys like
you ba ba ba that's a no-no I know maybe
it doesn't need a bone maybe use your up
with your vest but I would like to offer
my services run for mayor you're walking
front I'm telling you guys that could be
the real deal this little campaign of
ours has caught the attention of the
National Republican Party why are you
there
because crushing the last piece of hope
in your eyes really gets me off it's
good to see you
yeah you look fat it's on your boys game
on tons of presidents lots of money this
seems a bit crazy don't put all the
black ones in the center he's lying is a
moderate
there is the 18
and all you have is beer 20 bucks says I
do better with beer and you do with
change party can't win they're getting
desperate this is really just another
perfect example of the DC Li trying to
dictate how we should put that's we your
DC elite oh I know actually I'm from
here and some do like it
that's a lie that's a lie no that's what
are you even doing
[Music]
you
you